my citizens we are going to watch the most popular
DC EU movie the end of the DC extended Universe oh
man has arrived flopping its way into the island
it is Aquaman and the lost kingdom ladies and
gentlemen this came out when there was several
things out that we had to be very much present
for when it came to editing and stuff so I was
like there's no way I'm watching this in theaters
and I said all right sweet then I could just react
to it with these two gentlemen of course D John
Humphrey and the Andrew Gordon how are you Andrew
Ahoy I'm doing well I am so excited for the most
anticipated DCU film ever Amen to that brother
uh I was planning on re-watching the first one
last night but due to some scheduling errors
I wasn't able to so I had to do like editing
till really late at night did you guys rewatch
it I took care that for you don't wor both put
it on while making dinner awesome well I'm going
to rely on you two to remind me of certain things
things but I think I saw the first one twice in
the theater so should be all right hopefully but
you guys know what to do leave a like on this
video that would be exceptionally appreciated
also subscribe click the notification Bell to get
notified when we got a reaction up on this channel
that might peque your interest also thank you to
prepper for helping us edit down these highlights
as always the fulllength reaction watch along
that's where you sync up with your own copy
available for super sexy Rejects at our patreon
page thank you to all who have been joining
helping us have a awesome in patreon page over
there John and I cover several things exclusively
with highlights and watch alongs included all
right boys you ready to do this let's do it my
man man there's so much fish
look at all the fish yeah
whoa is that death sentence James won [Applause]
yeah we getting into black manta's backstory
there's this his back I feel like Aquaman just
going to save these people is what we're
getting right but Black Manta is also on
this ship and his dad's going to die again
everybody's good at something me I talk to
fish that's how I met my friends hey storm
storm from the X I need a lift he's my man
o some people think that makes me a joke
you're not a joke aqu man you know why
cuz I'm also good at something else bad
ass and that's breaking heads yeah let's
[Applause] go all the Pirates whoa I
knew idea why did you have to cut away
there oh okay those Chum lickers didn't stand
a chance Chum lickers fun name
the Chum [Applause] Bucket from
seat sorry pops my bad he's used to this
it's like I'm reading the script for Boba
Fett season 2 leave me alone oh yeah this
is my son you see four years ago everything
changed I met a woman I fell in love ever her
we entered her out of the movie wa this little
guy's the best who CG baby mouth there she
is she's in the movie see this kid he doesn't
[Music] sleep just how many badass sequences
oh right in the mouth I'm up with crack of
dawn because on top of getting married
and having a kid I finally got a job an
actual job on Hollywood Boulevard I'm
the king of freaking Atlantis I clock
in at 9:00 a.m. but then as it turned
out being King wasn't all it's cracked
up to be just metics oh dude yeah oh my
God who's he narrating to the only thing
that makes all the hard work and sleepless
nights worthwhile is hanging with my little
man you just pee on it like in the first movie
you just pee on it at least it wasn't a turd I
to keep got it that's cool am I going to
take down the legal cage fighter too wowe
oh awesome but for everything I get right
something else gets screwed [Music] up oh
quite a visual reaction to that fir truck
there John yeah I had one just like a
kid tomor Morris who really has the widest teeth
this is just b-roll of a day off on set he's on
that Norman Reus AMC show he's just having a lot
more fun being on land than he is in Atlantis so
he's going to need a little brother or sister
to play with that ain't happening this is the
last one yeah he's got a dog sh ious well how
lonely it was for you growing up an only child
hey he had a brother yeah it's true a half
brother don't be too hard on yourself turns
out I have a brother and he's a total back your
relationship with M isn't how it usually is you
be surprised or I'm not so sure about that cheer
siblings bicker and fight but at the end of the
day their family should be able to count on them
for help should be able to share Coronas with
them I'll still take the dog over him any day
should have a son and name him Lobo look at
that oh look out now Aqua Child holy crap who
would have thought hi baby boy you talking to the
fishies he's riding a new scene for them my whole
life I've wanted to share this gift with someone
you and me son are different a I can't wait to
introduce you to all the majestic creatures on
our planet Jason Mo has so much fun yeah I [Music]
know see the transition bring me a Happy [Music]
Meal oh no that's a title smash can't believe
the baby did that a Title Wave into a title
smash hey man this is moving at a Cheesy Pace
that feels intentional so I'm here for it I'm
having a good time yes I'm hoping I walk
away from this movie going I got it this
was for me is that the Black Manta theme
coordinates from Dr Shen nothing still no
sign of at planting remnants into the ice
oh look at a scar yeah it's badass funny
how his scar is diagonal but the Mantis
scar is straight down the low down you
know every day I don't fix my power suit is
another day Aquaman gets to live my power suit
where's my super suit check again we're close
this time I can feel it I'm going to be seeing
that discrepancy with the scar yeah should be
going down diagonal just do it right down the
center of his face 463 Dr Steven Shin recording
Randall Parks David Kane is losing his patience
if I don't turn up the atlantan technology he's
looking for soon they're probably going to kill
you you know what let's not even go there I'm sure
everything will be fine how are your magic lessons
coming along where is he going to visit Jack
torren yeah he's going to unearth them please
tell me you found some seismic Ray is going crazy
where's the epicenter standing on oh man hollower
you found exactly what you were
looking for it's no longer a wild goose
chase oh boy yeah I was going to
say that's usually the the sign
to run oh no a trench is opening up oh what a fun
shot oh oh oh damn ooo actually I'm sure this
was a Paar down cut down movie but in terms of
Direction I see more of James Juan's actual camera
style influence more than what I recall feeling
for the first one already well we're in more
tangible situations yeah so it's like less in the
computer
I think it was a piece of ice
sheet breaking off it was the title
card no there's an effect effect with
the sound effects oh there's that aect
[Music] no
sweet oo wa wait a minute oh oh see like it create
an actual symbol or a shape I think I
my got put some ice on it [Music] oh
wa anime tentacle
[Music] creature who found
the upside down oh oh my
God no
gloves that's James Juan horrror right
there who Mr cthulu and all these wide
angle lenses okay we're like 15 minutes in
I'm still having fun let's do a fun checkin
every five fun checkin the hell happened to
you oh there's something back there is it my
trench spin-off but on said James mom was
like referencing the thing the whole time
yeah I was thinking about that the thing meet
stranger things whoa questionable CGI there's
CGI how was this place even possible this
was all probably solid ice until we started
heating the planet it's all our faults
well thank God for global warming in my
right here here hell no I am anti Black Manta
now I mean no the tracks Le down there sud up
the tracks lead down there which means the
monster down there we're going to retrieve
Excalibur neat it's going to be like that
James Cameron water cave movie I don't
believe this it's a structure of some kind and
there's more bued in the very good observation
everyone out and search yes sir we stumbled upon
something big here duck this is heavy this has to
be a few thousand years old astounding it's
going to be great on my YouTube channel so
he's just trying to find Tech to make his black
mantis suit more oh my God he's having so much
more fun here that's so freaky I wonder how many
of those trench spin-off ideas got folded into
this uh
oh oh that's creepy oh nice
nice oh what was the plan here
exactly oh come on man kick his ass kanen
yeah oo just tell the monster you want revenge on
Aquaman he'll understand stand just ask to borrow
some of his power nicely I don't know maybe on
TV it looks better but so far the effects look
really great other than the times when they don't
but some of them most of the time they look all
right oh oh there's more of an assured hand I feel
with the camera work that tried
a war to the wise is it the black
Trident W yeah let's go fun oh yes yes free
me from my PR I will grant you the strength
to kill the man who murdered your father no
he's using you kind of you need to live so
you can kill that son of a [__] that was
his back story from what he stole from you
oh now it's premonition terrain his home
will burn his kingdom will very Avengers
Age of Ultron wow his entire life set a flame
D DAV DAV David I I'll cut you I'll cut you
squid crap [Music] battle I'm just going to
say it if if Sam ry's name was slapped onto
this I think people would be a lot more
forgiving I think it' be the exact same
shot movie like feel like a Sam Ry movie
they let him do his thing you guys see
that oh no oh God what are you doing here be
careful on the bed the council has called for
an emergency Gathering there's been another plague
outbreak son of a [__] hey that was a good line
delivery all right was it I thought it was the
worst line delivery in the entire movie John I
have listened to every line delivery in history
of Cinema the surface has been poisoning our
atmosphere for over a century we fixed that last
time you can't expect them to care about what
happens to us if they don't even know we exist if
you want to be a part of the conversation we have
to take our seat at the table H like wakanda the
high table it's time for Atlantis to reveal itself
to the surface let's call Batman and get on this
maybe some other time and I know this is against
our Traditions but the world is shrinking and the
old ways aren't going to protect us anymore can't
be isolationists I like how his hair is moving
but does not look like he's underwater know have
you already forgotten that this plague killed
k your own beloved mentle oh okay there's our
William defo did they just kill off Willam defo
I pretty sure they just said that maybe he'll
show up to surprise us if we ever decide to make
ourselves known to the surface dwellers it will
be to eradicate them not to coexist but I bought
that coexist bumper sticker so he needs to go to
the surface and he's dealing with Black Manta
again okay a lot of stuff from the first movie
but it's kind of rare for a like these com movies
to feel like a direct sequel to the last one sure
you know sure sure no really just like let's got
brand new this brand everything's brand new whole
new phase New Era new everything there and I have
the whole Kingdom helping us that little baby boy
still kicking our asses and you taking care of me
raising me on your own where the hell is Nicole
Kidman she's filming an AMC commercial ah you're
the real superhero we are I am Bubba Fett vocal
told me to bring the land and the Sea together
problem is half of Atlantis still wants to
destroy the surface it won't listen I can't bring
[__] together voo believed in you here here I I
know I'm missing we do too the audience what
a crck of [__] it's like the worst sequel
thing you can do yeah it is annoying
I just keept going you celebrate the
wins you mourn the losses and you wake up
the next day and you do it again sometimes
not giving up is the most heroic thing you
can do these zooms have me expecting a jump
scare oh speaking aori that's my native
native tongue oh dude I wish speak it so
I could know what they said too
they they said uh I am Bubba he
called him my man and then Arthur said
that's badass somewhere in the Atlantic
what a cool set yeah is it just because my
expectations were so low that I am enjoying
I feel like I've enjoyed this more than the
first one sure sure it's just it just seems
like it's really embraced The Voice the
fun voice so far I'm definitely enjoying
it more than the first one so far he's
got a suit he's got cool Wolverine suit
humans were not made to live at these depths
you just remember who built this ship more
worried about how long ago they built
it they literally look like the X-Men
in X3 like I like the Retro bovie SciFi
look that they they have with this right
[Music] now this feels like alien with
a combination of fantasy you know feel
like I'm watching like a really big budget
Power Rangers well that's how I felt with
the first one oh no he's got the nose blood
Expedition log day 613 jeez Kane is off on
our most dangerous Mission yet a three-man
octobot infiltration team [Music] wa these
ancient machines we found still function
after all these years but they require very
specialized fuel to keep them running Kane
calls it orac Calcom uh-oh I'll remember
that it's that malevolent Spirit suddenly he
knows secrets that he couldn't possibly know
including the only way to obtain this oric
alcome is to steal it from highly protected
storage vaults wow he also informed me there
wasn't enough time to show this all happening
so I had to record this monologue to get it out
of the way quick say the time frame on this is a
bit confusing said 5 months later what was the 6
but this is the 613th day that they've been on a
journey okay you have 15 minutes to get in
and out no margin for error you can't go
through the In-N-Out driveway in 15 minutes
no depends what time and night hardly ever
yes this should take you through oo buddy
those are pretty cool ships yeah I like
the designs of them for sure I got like the
swirling that left to right like a fan octopus
legs wowe open sesame nice lens flares man
stay vigilant we have no idea what kind
of security measures they have down
there they got a guard just hanging
out he talks like the octopus from
Madagascar yeah this is like a swashbuckling
video game yeah it's a fetch Quest I'm thought
that was Henry Cav we got no reason to defend this
this is the last one does us no favor you know
burn it all down if we if we must but also this
kind of fun this is really fun loading barge now
wowe oh no we're trapped it's a trap change
of plans I need an extraction now oh h to
battle station oh two arms there's
so much diversity in this movie woke
Atlantis I found it it exists I'm in
traffic you are illegally here you are out of
Transit Zone doctor power up the Sonic battery
illegal border crossing will be met with deadly
force no oh no commencing charge it's pretty cool
how much bigger of a role they gave him they
really follow through with that hydro cannon
at front gate locking in on target charger
set to maximum power Intruder in sight take
them out oh no oh what are you waiting for
fire oh no don't fire on your discovery oh
no oh they got some real weapons whoa
like a sonar gun oh D oh [__] going
ham so imposing the stakes have been raised
sir atlantan hostiles are approaching split
up oh now it feels real yeah The Zo vault is
that Nicole Kidman we just saw there we go hey
what heartbreak feels good on a shark like
this I like the armor the sharks have it's pretty
cool watch out for the civilians oh my goodness
great oh no they're they're
date they're me cute woo w
awesome come on Atlanta come on how cool
I'm watching an anime man this is so
[Music]
Funt it's a good good looking out shark merge onto
the freeway maximum speed of 600
knots speed let's go Amber let's go
Queen oh excellent look how freaking
cool this is come on like a turtle no
no little dude it's like in Star
Trek when they're in warp speed
whoa oh that is so cool wow gave a
pretty badass moment got me [Music]
oh is this the moment she punches it yes
ooh oh [__] wa nice implosion oh damn
oh ooh ruthless not yet I'm going to kill
me a dead mermaid oh what that suit looks
so much better than the first movie oh no oh
no my bad man get away from my wife keep my
wife's name out your mouth oh wow atlantian
Army is headed this way if we don't leave now
we're dead got to get my revenge oh my god oh
crap save those [Music] people I get revenge
first who cares about these people that's
fair excellent tracking shot yeah [Music] a
ah
J nice Toby would be proud yes I think
this feels more tangible and lived in
wa oh wowe the Sonic come on [__] A what wow
nice it's like being an Aquaman's perspective so
sudden damn and the soundtrack is much better
so far too dude that was a great action scene
yeah that was a genuinely great action scene
H with it the throne is the heart of at too
often now it stands empty while our King spends
half his time on l oh they're questioning him
tragedy is merely a taste of the Havoc that
will be rought I'm okay put her in a back to
tank cannot protect his own family a how is he
supposed to protect us dude hats off to rert
Cs and Williams I'm really enjoying the score
so far those Gregson Williams mans do we know
what was Thorn Aqua beards he escaped with a large
stockpile of orul am I supposed to know what that
is power source that was used in ancient times it
emits tremendous amounts of greenhouse gases that
are highly destructive to our planet in fact we
almost destroyed the oceans ourselves before we
realized what we were doing they almost made the
same mistakes as the humans can't be disposed of
safely so the remaining stockpile has been buried
in 12 storage vaults deep underground no we should
one the other places that are throwing this stuff
it's already been there it's all gone emptied
them all out this spike in global temperatures
that's causing disasters on the surface making
the seadweller sick happened 5 months ago he's
using the storm or calom to heat the planet he
made the title card he must be stopped or a
global climate meltdown is imminent we need
to find I feel like this is topical what do you
mean I think I know someone that might build to
help us you're not going to like it your brother
oh yeah he's the only one who might know how to
find him in time the fisherman will never allow
you to speak to him he killed her King yeah I
wasn't exactly going to ask for permission my dad
told me to talk to him he's like I saw Thor the
Dark World I can work with my brother I'm going to
break him out myself Arthur Caron is looking for a
reason waa this looks weird what's going on here
out there where I belong where I'm actually good
at what I do tired of nothing ever getting
done this looking so strange What's Happening
Now else a it's a lot of stuff it's the CG hair
it's the lighting the CG face elements don't do
closeup let me not get caught all right this
is straight up toward the Dark World o it's
got a very different energy I just mean the
plan secret one of aind underground facility
they're assuming no sea dweller would ever dare
cross the desert nice special outfit for you is
that boys exra medum chat Force change color
and camouflage you for up to a minute making
you undetectable who it's the most sens they'll
never see you coming that's pretty cool at least
for the minute that you can use it are too risky
I'll be sending a yeah they they really made them
edit this down yep I'm thinking they making
it work though that's an octopus T that's a
drummer my friend too for sure too too Chico
engineered intelligence for infiltration and
Espionage he also plays a variety of musical
instruments Topo he does like in the first
movie where he played drums toppo gets an
expanded role well he was the most popular
character in The First movie your hect starting
to smell like warm CH butter man there's a lot
of uh lot of liquid splatting on Aquaman jokes
is ink piss you just pee on it like the first
movie Death woring Aesthetics surv and dry by
turning to blood they're like evil groots cool
they're limiting his water supply just enough
to keep him alive sure and if you do see arm
you tell him that I love him yes Queen fr I
mean Atlanta once you broken arm out you're
not going to be able to turn your back on him
you need him but you can never trust him so kill
him oh damn oh oh no tase me bro Patrick Wilson
shirtless Patrick Wilson's always shirtless
yes look at him
go
oh my God such a cool design on these dudes yeah
it actual practical makeup oh we're
in like Army of Darkness right now
[Music] oh wow they really made it seem
like this was going to be a real challenge
yes but they did it in 3 minutes what the
hell are you you doing here I'm going to
break you out if you lost your mind you must
be very desperate you're the one who put me
here why you bringing up [__] I got to
stop David Kan from destroying the world
and you're the only one that can help me
so you do the math do they CGI it must a
CGI down his body right uh it looks like
it Cast Away crab Wilson let's roll crab
[Music] Wilson oh so what he like gets dipped in
water and he'll get his muscles back or something
I would imagine so yeah this changes nothing
yeah wouldn't have it any other way little
brother just give us 20 minutes of screen time
then we'll Bond call me half brother come on
too you stupid squid wake up and open the door
you Ain so mad at the squid for the seod trust
me it wasn't my idea hey put some respect on
toppo's name he's doing [__] none of you
could do he's squeezing into tight spaces come
on all right oh my God creatures are so icky and
cool look they they didn't get Willam to Thro but
they did get William to Thro from last temptation
of Jesus Christ you know how to ride one of these
are you kidding I don't even know what the hell it
is Ride The Finger monster who yeah
yeah there's a lot of sing looking creatures in
this [Music] one reminds me of Batman's wallall
crawler in Zack Snider's Justice League
there you go it's a tribute to the SN
cut oh yeah who oh damn they burrow what a
specific kind of creature was pretty inventive to
me get out of here stay out
I just wanted you off my
back I love how it was like 10 minutes
ago they introduced breaking him out
and then made his whole like it's going to
be this this this this and it's extremely
simple well he's got the Predator suit
so I mean you know oh no save him orm
take back our
prize water oh yeah in the just get him in the
water all you need is a little bit he's like Percy
Jackson yeah this is when you get off and
you go on foot when he's this close to the
water is when you get off and go off yeah all
we need is a tide boy all we need is a tide
let's go oh my God he's being baptized he's
being rehydrated hydrate level four please is
it ready oh yeah wow nice detail with I need to
stop working out I just need to go into [Music]
water let's go let's go oh looks like Alexander
scars guard now yeah Tarzan over here badass
way
wowe whoa what the hell yeah you can't save
that weird looking CGI with a frame rate change
man oh nice nice dude hell
yeah sidekick [Laughter]
literally oh King [__] to do back in Atlanta go
come this run doing like a low-key Naruto run yeah
why isn't he moving his arms what's up with his
arms the real King has returned yeah but he has
a bunch of fanatic loyalists down here give
every your try that or should be reinstated
you know if the pressures of leadership are too
stressful perhaps you should leave and let someone
who knows what they're doing be king I agree let
Tapo be the king just help me find this [__] my
contact will at least know where to look he looks
so uncomfortable I know look like they have to
like force themselves to squeeze into I knew was
ruthless but he wasn't insane J this guy just put
a gun to the world's head and pulled the trigger
without even making any demands he's drunk with
power I don't know about this whole like possessed
thingy I thought his motivation was enough yeah
but he's got to be powerful enough yeah but her
layer of some type of weird possession thing I
agree with you but he got he got his ass kicked
so easily in the first movie so they had to give
him have him power up I'm just talking about The
Possession part I'm just talking power okay the
power part I get Andrew I think his look is
cool with the green eyes but like this whole
he's insane because of the [Music] thingy this is
giving me almost like a Krypton feel from Man of
Steel Snider tributes Snider [Applause] tribute
and green like Kryptonite and and this could
destroy our world like a Kryptonite with Superman
I didn't think we'd ever actually have to use it
on anyone wants to go back to Atlantis we are this
close to unlocking the greatest power in human
history are you you really telling me you want
to walk away now yeah if it's going to destroy
the world if I said yes would you like me wait a
minute sure you want to see how long you last in
that jungle was that always the angle of the scar
be my guest okay they would have messed that up
you would you would hope but no yeah it was coming
from that cheek up to that side of his forehead at
least yeah I'll Stick Around stick around they
scavenged ships from around the world to build
this place cool it is the one place in the world
where the scum of the land and sea mingle scum of
the land and see come on it is where people come
to disappear an impressive [__] hole how have
I never heard of this place before it's not meant
to be common knowledge it's a pirate Haven [__]
lantis listen I don't know if you know this about
me but I'm not too popular of pirates I dress like
Johnny Deber earlier and it did not go well and
there's a lot of R here too oh I'm well wereare
you can't trust him relax it was the only way to
get us both in Hammerheads whoa It's Blade Runner
underwater different dude on the drums though let
my man toppo get in there they're all different
creatures John it's like the Contin only too could
play the drums yeah they've got way more sci-fi
this time that's Kingfish he Brokers deals with
pirates mercenaries slavers you name it Street
Sharks helping out he's are best shot at finding
Manta and he's not going to tell us anything if
you go in there flexing your muscles at him
do the peck dance you think you I'm strong I
didn't realize you've been released from prison
Martin Short Jaba I literally just said that in
my head we need to find David Kane bad news
David Kane is no longer on the market oh he's
slowely running as an independent operator and
a Smooth Operator where does he hold up now in
exchange I offer a favor my brother a sexual
favor from the king of Atlantis you seriously
expect me to play footy with someone with that
kind of blood on their hands I don't hurt him
I've run rings around you logically if the
information checks out good promise you that
I won't immediately come back here and tear
this place part oh with that kind of a deal
traditionally the kings of Atlantis have turned
a blind eye to the sunken Citadel now we have to
Blind it for you oh offer him a seat at the table
man I like the look of a lot of this but it's not
exactly the most gripping stuff Muses no no no
take it easy on the Street Sharks [Music] yeah
head
wowe what chaos
wow oh damn oh no is it it going to explode
I don't know where he is but there have been
rumors a a dormant volcano in the South Pacific
called Devil's deep oh badass name Travelers
say there's a jungle there now navigation
gets scrambled as soon as you start to get
close and if you get too close you don't come
back oh and believe me I am I'd say that SP K
is hiding out whoa or whoa that's kind of
what I kind of summarizes this whole movie
yeah we got what we needed next scene let's
get out of here we got we got more PL to get
on deep sea Rihanna uh yeah we are St after once
we got to or breakout point I started feeling like
okay the trim down stuff is I think starting to
actually affect my experience with this movie
yep starting to feel a bit like a highlight reel
if anything it's even easier now we couldn't have
planned it any better than American Werewolf
in London who are you talking to mirror mirror
on the wall who is the blackest Manta of all
somewhere it is at a point where I'm like okay
I need the noise to slow down a time a little
bit just a t starting to become a little loud
woo I've seen this Pixar short but when the action
kicks in it is really like I think the I think the
action is really great oh yeah you know would be
amazing right now reinforcements great big greasy
cheeseburger and a pine of Guinness now this feels
like Predator the words that surface dwellers give
their food sound disgusting enjoying half the
world what do you think about that you're lost
dude love how are the intense situations become
the goofier Arthur because yeah man that's how
he copes what is it oh my God no one no one
oh he's totally pranking him oh yeah shrimp
of the land oh my God that looks like a real
roach too that's funny it's not now but that's
funny got protein oh my god dude and I mean
a coconut like a good coconut not a rotten
coconut would be like you know Mother Nature
you know that's not even man's food it's not
surface dweller food pandor don't say stuff
like that when I'm already thinking half the
time what happens if James what would
happen if James came C directed this
you know he did an Entourage guys you
got to get this out of your head about
James Cameron and all that oh are you seeing
this it's not normal oh they're like on Skull
Island it's what happens when you
put that green crap in there or
the Predator bleed all over it 20 a
months you just ate that roach wow
that is a big rat is sad oh no pizza
rat rest in peace wow we are on Skull
Island great location you guys ate the
Cockroach I am wondering low key like
I bet nothing will happen but at the same time
run like that I don't know I'm used to run it's
like I saw used to swimming [Laughter] like
holy sh [__] yeah that's awesome thank you
giant plant okay that's CGI this is very much
like a video game this [Music] movie whoa what
a wild cacophony of plant life oh [__]
wow I like it more than the latest Indiana
Jones movie that was the best one what
are you talking about who's that what's
that say writing this ancient atlantan
through King builds Bridges hey look at
that
ow oh my God this really is a video
game it worked oh it did work
building a bridge unless it
breaks in half luckily it didn't break
half hey I forgot to tell you she loves
you you told me this now I'm just tired of
waiting for the right moment I'm just tired
of waiting for them to let us let this movie
breathe normally so I'm just going to tell you
now wowe oh yeah these things
have Hops and wings oh wow
don't all those bugs have wings I think they were
grasshopper I don't know Jason mimo just relies
so much on having fun that at times I don't even
care because sometimes they'll do like they'll
cut to the next line of his at a different shot
and it just doesn't seem like it's transitioning
smooth from the previous shot like screw it he's
having fun yeah you can't deny his Charisma energy
even though it feels like they shot this at a
different time of day or a different day in total
what's contagious too is energy like comes on to
us as well oh pick it up unlock your inner power
uh don't put them together is it going
to be some Rush finale villain or a post
credit scene this is the dceu we could
get another black atom [Music] dude
yes same guy's going to be
like I've been waiting for you
wowe the dead armies armies of dun
Harrow she touching my stuff okay doc you want
to know my plan so bad yeah I kind of forget
you're in this movie I'm going to kill Aquaman
and destroy everything he holds dear I thought
we already knew that I'm going to murder
his family and burn his kingdom to Ash I
will avenge my father m oh boy I have to make
a deal with the devil to do it sure David you
can't trust the Trident four out of five dentists
agree I never draw this blade unless it's going
to taste blood oh pray I never show it to you
again oh you just broke the rule of the blade
oh it had to taste blood Fair fa you got him on
the loophole he's so much more intimidating in
this film obviously he's got way more screen time
but still I guess I still think he could be a lot
better I feel like with his actual character
motivation he could be more intimida but I
like that he's here he's more effective yeah
than the last one for sure I just thought he
was so cheesy in the last one yeah look Loki
I'm not asking for your advice Loki he called
him lowy that's what I said earlier Thor the Dark
World go back to askat for all I making all they
Embrace what they were doing I think this one is
more self-aware by a lot that's what I'm saying
they're embracing what they're doing you're
the one who swam through the front gate and
challenged my claim for the throne only because
you're trying to destroy the surface world if you
weren't such an [__] you'd still be king wait
wait you took my throne and you don't even want
it are you kidding me I hate this job he could
be the King again from the day my father found
out you existed he prepared me for the moment that
you would come and challenge me for the throne oh
that's really sad especially when you think how
easily I kicked your ass with basically no prep
time once while I didn't even stretch that day
but was it really you or the Trident just saying
no look at this look at there's such
a retro vibe to it yeah it's a retro
it's like amalgamation of like retro
sci-fi B movies swashbuckling video
games it's like Uncharted if if it was
Aquaman or something I don't know unch
Aquaman there's something like a real fun sets
and the depths look real you it does feel like
you're watching The Hobbit or something
in terms of like how the ruction values
are coming together and this is a nice one cool
tracking shot yeah do one of those glass things
yeah
nice woo boom don't want to be your monkey wrench
let me kill him what was the problem with shooting
he you know you probably murdered that guy
sibling rivalry that guy's more than likely
dead this whole place must be heat shielded to
protect it from the surfaces thermal satellites
question is how do we stop I take out this
reactor we would have to Crater the entire
Island get away from there oh no come on you agree
with them you like Atlantis this Blaster may be
ancient but it was built for killing atlantans
real intimidating don't try to mean mugget
man okay I am so sorry I did not mean I'm a
scientist David Kane said he could help me
but now he won't let me leave you expect us
to believe you have nothing to do with this
I know I've done things I'm not proud of um
but he would have killed me if I hadn't knock
him out no no no then I'll knock him out
no oh but I want to knock someone out you
can come with us thank you he's going to die
right now it's a direct link to some ancient
evil it gives Cain great powers and in with great
responsibility no and he's got no resp he takes no
responsibility ouch cheese I do
find it funny how there hasn't
been much like I hate when that happens
making F of so many seen and the last
one just explode to a next scene he's
barely done like actual Aquaman action
[Music] whoa boom Boomerang nice Captain
Boomerang Suicide Squad yeah Dam geometry
he is just murdering humans left and right it's
okay it's not Batman yeah anybody else can do it
oh Dam that's spooky he can't hear it yep it's
way too low reminded me when the alien came out
the xenomorph and Aliens out of the water for n
you got nothing but references Andrew that's on
me woo
ouchies damn that
[Applause] shot damn Foot Right the camera that's
great camera work man that's some great ass camera
work now he knows how to sell it James Juan
knows how to bring the movie m magic together
save him [Music] Arthur that's my brother yeah
you do that to family oh ouch cheese ooh where
the hell is black man they're not making a lot of
noise or anything no no no no no not the or Calum
you want to blow us up this stuff blows up yes
this stuff blows up of course it blows up let's
see some yes D look how humongous those chains
are they're like comically big Anchors Away woo
yeah there like get a slime sound effect just
there it's just funny like oh nice you're the
AT-AT walker in this experiment I I like that
sequence a lot because they're they have
to utilize their super strength but kind
of like Jackie Chan ask use items around
them that are just so massive that only a
superhuman could physically move it around
yeah there he is David or my guard I never
expected to see you two fighting side by
side nor did we just for you damn it that
posture they have't in I was going to
kill you last but thanks for dropping
by action scene two oh he should have dropped
something when you said thanks for dropping
by oh oh damn nice come at me
the killer of King come at me
bro [Music]
woo ah just love stacking up against these
massive industrial items dang don't touch
it ah oh no oh no The Taste the taste that
was at land we just saw yeah wowe oh God
get him in the water he's got mirrored
get him in the water that was a cool
shot of [Music] atan whoa starfish
take that Island down nous let's go
King oh sweet you show that mean Island whose
boss oh yeah war [Music]
war yeah let's [Music] go wow that's I I do think
they such a great job on the scale when you see
like the human characters against everything else
like I like that they let the humans look tiny in
comparison yeah it's really colorful too yeah
well I mean a lot of these movies can be very
dra and gray [Music] [Applause] like oh the Sonic
Cannon I'm going to go kill your father and baby
help him
arm water [Music] physics Ora yes Queen chills
everywhere she's in the movie now wrap your
legs around him I'm sorry to drag you all under
this but the fisherman can't think that Atlant
was involved now this looks like Power Rangers
Kingdom has not forgotten its debt to you you
may count on us always so count as one what you
guys always make the comments at the same time
it's like in a in a race to com comment YouTu
what is what who was that I know he can't be
trusted and he cut off my claw that sounds like
pet Reese Davies John Reese Davies [Laughter] I
saw the lost kingdom you remember he in Indiana
Jones how do you know what you saw was the lost
kingdom oh they said the name of the movie It's
called necris oh and I didn't just see it I knew
it NEC during King ATL's time there were seven
United Kingdoms of Atlantis and the black city
was a curse upon them all uh-oh everyone looks
so much more saturated on that land yeah she
knows like everyone's color is just so much for
striking by exploiting oracal necris rapidly
became a superpower unlike any other but it came
at a terrible price poisoning the land wowe ATL's
own brother cordex cordex to stop using it before
the world was irrevocably damaged it's that guy
it's euron gr Droid thinking his own brother was
trying to steal his power they definitely didn't
cut out any of his scenes nope instrument of evil
the black Trident One Trident to rule them all he
transformed his people and himself into monsters
he made the Orcs to fight Atlantis so the two
brothers went to war God oh my God they can't
have history repeat itself they have to change
this o and imprisoned him at all of necris
with a spell cast with his own blood ah is s
to ensure that cord's dark power would never be
found y'all got to start destroying this [__]
outright and not just burying it evil was supposed
to remain Frozen for eternity Let It Go but David
Kane has found it and it's slowly possessing
him oh Alan used blood magic to steal cordex
in his prison only Allan himself could release
him Manta doesn't need atlet himself man needs
atan blood duh the key to cord's prison is
the Royal bloodline itself what does that
mean he needs blood from either you me or Arthur
that's what it means guys oh my God I just put
it together just now when he said that we're The
End Of The Bloodline oh no no we're not the baby
do it movie now it's turned into Ghostbusters 2
precedented weather events across the globe and
meteorologists are at a loss to explain this rapid
there's so many dead animals in this movie one
of's going to die oh no if they kill the baby big
respect bold movie bold move oh nice that was sick
shot [Music] no Jesus that's C you dead baby papa
and and the baby I'm sorry
son where what do you care
J no oh yeah baby oh no I love this movie
oh my God that was so funny I think them
telling them to parir it down sometimes
is is the best thing they could have done
cuz then you get past all other [__] it's
like they probably want to dramatically hit
so hard where you're like I can't take
this serious aam's razor man sometimes
the simplest answer is the best did you
see that one two three no no no so funny
I'll never forget that meant to be taken
seriously but laughable move over Vader's
no oh is broadcasting on an old Atlantean sonar
frequency it's Morse code bring a little one back
yes don't have this conversation with your
wife I like that they got with your mom you
really do forget that that is also mea's baby I
like that they got she ran out screaming I was
like why is she so upset oh that's right promise
me you will protect each other promise me more
or I'm going to do my [Music] best family a the
aqua fam like that they brought Atlanta's theme
back from the first film oh a reference to the
actual thing we're watching I was going to say
that's a reference to my family cuz you know
I have a mom and a brother right I would have
made sense I ruined [Laughter] it our only
chance is to hit him with total overwhelming
force from every direction not with Junior and
the crossfire something about DOL lundon it's
got like a little bit of a dude thing going
on this movie what if we disrupt those Echoes
with another sound wave on the same frequency
but just it's much much louder the loudness
Wars that's going to be the easy part oh we are
true disruptors Arthur you got so dumb after all
I've been spending my time my Muscle Beach when
I'm not the throne give me some sunad oil man
I am the weapon I don't need it
he's not just capable of grabbing
it oh dude and then Dwayne Johnson's going
to throw the missile at it in a minute mean
a stronger reference probably would have been
galado do showing up at the top like at the
end of that's fair yeah because she's in both
franchises you know so Dwayne Johnson that's
right the power hierarchy did change didn't it
all we did was fast forward things a few years
yeah this was already going to happen power up
the Sonic can drop the beat is he going to see
the air of his ways I hope not love how they
made this one notee villain from Aquaman 1
even more one not I know just with much more
screen time how do we take a character that
would have been fine enough on its own and
play into one of the worst tropes of our own
franchise
oo [Applause] yeah it's the
title sequences yeah the
premonition oh my God you could roll an emck this
oh yeah the Dodge it all the day after
[Music] tomorrow oh here we go fishes
[Music]
assemble oh no the whales are [Music] pissed
whoa can ship take them all out they're just
animals aren't they just regular animals there's
a whole realm of power that sea creatures have
that we are just unaware of taste of your
own medicine wow wowe did the the fish they
did that they just combine the power of all of
their sonar high pitch frequencies and overwhelm
the system I guess is that what happened that's
what I took from that I took what he took thank
you for that explanation John any old time
okay sorry guys this movie is too smart for
me that's really why they need to reboot the
DCU just flying over everyone's heads [Music]
damn that is Icky looking it's like a skull
peering down Into the Depths Back to Where it
All Began is immense it could be anywhere the
throat of necris is in the heart of the city
I sense Something In The Water everyone light
it up light it up constellations you say that
cardx turned his people people into an army of
monsters yes I did uh imminent action sequence
ahead oh no where is Will woo damn no
music to compliment it's crazy yes Queen
this would be a good time to call in all
those an mammals ooh nice go now and save
the prince thank you your in whoa whoa whoa
thank you Mr Crabs CGI was really off [Music]
yeah I don't know what I'm looking at
I mean there are a lot of invertebrates
under the sea I don't even know John
ree Davies is supposed to be he's Mr
Krabs release the armies of dun Haro
sometimes the the speed on the
CGI of the humans is so weird
yeah Oh e use your axe yeah man oh no not show
him you're a better person now not
now dude no his expression he like
really hey
a fine I have no other tentacles just the one I
needed I mean orm's not a bad guy oh sign of
respect oh damn I mean did good barnica boy
was orm really ever a bad guy you know he just
had some bad uh bad some bad policies you where
he was coming from man they're why wouldn't
you what we live in America was like screw
these people going to war step our foot in other
people's Wars and I was like you know this makes
sense oh my dude you did it ah well he's clearly
going to be be the king at the end of this yeah
yeah wa damn the double tap let's go
she she's just like a little Easter egg
character oh let's go Uncle Shin damn baby must
be freezing oo to grow spine ouch he's not wrong
[Music]
oh the knife the blood knife of
blood nautical baby monitor
bam that was a good line to learn War
Blood come get it yeah man let's do
it Go Mermaid Man go woo when will the
beat drop King Shin aquan no one calls
him Aquaman I know he only been called it
like twice including that one damn dude
that was a great shot yeah tell man look
at this [__] this is way cooler let's
go Aquaman Warehouse fight Trident versus
Trident this is a badass shot yeah dude
woo damn it's like an anime it really
is
oo orm save him you wear my brother's arm
and wield his stdent but you're only half
the man he was I am 10 times the King Mufasa
was let's go every time I say that Mara saves
him Mera just keeps showing up in a nick
of time yeah she's the MVP of the movie
she's in the movie that's our baby yes
it is his stand over it for a second
go oh [__] whoa yeah Snider shot going to
look at it oh yeah Barnacle Boy run fight
it free me from my prison all my power
will be yours no don't listen as Sauron
this Sor oh oh green eyes are
gone from him ah damn it damn
it barnacle Bo kill him and you will
be Ocean Master again no fall into a
side splits either you kill your brother or
you die it's just a dead ey don't listen to
it
a the blood the blood the mouth blood destroy the
Trident the Bin's blood is Magic magic is broken
Magic it again I'm done find your puppet's cax
I'm coming for you who you doing watching this
don't let him take it hasn't he taken it up
already that's from the first movie it's time
for me to reclaim my destiny you can have
it you were foolish to think he could ever
change you are the one true king it l deserves
it's one true king just hopping around between
both yeah he's literally playing both sides and
the one true king don't worry you're going to
be the King by the end of the movie calm down
you both need to put it down you know there
was a time when I wanted to meet you more than
anything let you know that you weren't alone
that we were in it together that's from the
first movie protect each other this from this
movie come full circle this development is just
so compelling no matter what you are not alone
or this together oh he got the teardrop Aqua tier
Let it go Let it go Let it go can't hold it back
anymore I live again I waited come for centuries
in the dark for this moment after 10,000 years I'm
free who [__]
why would that work my [__]
wow oh go yeah yeah there we go there we
go destroy it yeah just like in The Suicide
Squad ooo it's like I live
again for 30 seconds damn
best DC EU villain ever black man is the second
one let him die look let him
have an unceremonious death
he didn't save his father is he going to save
him bring It full circle art come out oh he's
going to save him I just hope a rock hits
him don't beg the ocean for forgiveness are you
going to take his hand though just fall just fall
psych it's so generic what a tragic
death oh no they even they even had
them trim that down we need the
mid credit scene showing how he
survived there you go perfect for 10 10 out of
10 you're going to the Olympics couples diving
Dr sh can you swim yeah it's okay he can survive
sub subzero temperatures come on baby what the
[Music] [__] everyone gets a ride that Dr Shin
survived this woo look at those water Sims but
what happened to Mr Krabs yeah what happened to
Mr Krabs so Dr Shin just like got here all dry
and yep he's good he just got thrown up by that
squid machine and he's fine his regular survive
in Antarctica just a regular human thank you
dude take him to Atlantis astounding astounding
hey that still only comes us one my carw got cut
off your debt is paid not everybody's going to
see it that way though might as is why be king
it's too bad you went and had yourself killed
back there love this cliche all this ice it'd be
impossible to find the body I love this cliche
orm spin-off let's go keep him in the DC gun verse
may need to call you up for some advice you know
with the whole running a kingdom thing and then he
spins off into his own 18am franchise interesting
really thought he was going to end up being King
brother the emotional Arc is complete now kiss
yeah the forearm shake you son of a [__] the
shake of Kings you do the right thing when doing
the wrong thing is much easier and you're willing
to ask for help even from your worst enemy you
really took Dumbledore's [Laughter] advice if
you lead Atlantis will follow now do a barrel
roll after all true king builds Bridges right
that knock down a statue thought that was just
a metaphor your metaphor might have just
saved the world's ass I'm going to get a
burger oh my God is it over we got Dr Shin where's
Dr Shin entire civilization hidden for thousands
of years about to be revealed where's the UN
none of this is going to [Music] matter oh
my God the king of Atlantis has reached out to
the United Nations and will be it's literally
it really is that ending the result of weeks
of secret negot ation with the United Nations
we now go live would people be wowed by it we
got a Superman already but not from under the
sea I mean it's different it's like you've had
a hidden civilization for so long I come here
today as a representative of Two Worlds the
land and the Sea and I stand here as proof
change is coming to both and I'm calling for
Global Unity absolutely Atlanta stands ready
to help contribute its science and technology that
b did it seem strange unfamiliar cheeseburger the
you got the burger you called it joh bur oh
I'm the king of Atlantis I am Iron Man I am
Aquaman you got to do that you got do
the Iron Man thing literally just mic
dropped literally mik dropped the end of the movie
Bravo Never Comes did the story I didn't know
that how many people have set like movies
to this song I want a list of all the movies
that use this song as like a badass character
Theme all right everyone guess them mid
credits or post credits in go oh they
both get a burger no wait that he gets
a divorce from Queen Mera uh a teas are
for Boba Fett no it's Black Manta surviving in
all the green stuff that's right third billing
baby b to be or to be wild Martin Short called
that [__] I called that [__] yeah I had a
I thought that was him when I was listening to
that voice John looked it up on IMDb I looked
the whole movie and plot lineup and all the
cast and the guy from from Game of Thrones he
spoke one line and you were like it's smart
and short yeah I know his voice anywhere and
then the more he kept talking I started to have
doubts but it all paid off in the end nah Henry
caval put a roach on
it put a roach on it
that's the Cockroach from SpongeBob
yeah that that's the best med credit scene
call that [__] that's still better than
the flash post credit scene I called that
[__] hey you actually did you called the
cheeseburger you called that you just all over
it I called these uncal things well you know
what I think the costume were looking fresh
this time around everyone was really popping
popping because of the attire they be wearing
John do the hair thing oh yeah squid do it for
real you can't do the real version
not anymore where he's like oh wow
I'm going to try to do the oh subtle draw
attention I want to see where it's like the
wind is blowing but not underwater
I'm trying to promote the shirts
guys nothing oh take it away well I got my
America's ass shirt on of homelander here
and he's got his nip chills John do the hair
thing I got the VNA game that was more natur
you're getting it down there you go guys reject
Nation shop.com thank you so much to everyone
who has been supporting the channel in the most
miraculous way about picking yourself up some
attired or representing yourself as a citizen
of this great reject nation and we got all
these kinds of shirts right here that have been
amazing Sellers and it makes me just so happy to
see because we're involved with pretty much all of
them uh creatively wise and and we got more coming
this year so hop on board the reject Nation train
and get yourself a tea and you look good while
doing it while supporting the channel oh yeah B
listening to so Apple on Spotify we just watched
Aquaman and the lost kingdom people now now now
might I might I kick this off please might no
no best moment in the entire movie best reaction
ever from Greg let's give it so funny that was
hilarious I all right so before watching this I
really had no interest in watching it honestly
like it has two of us it had gone down so much
the first trailer was like ah this is fine it
was more the same and then the second trailer was
like I don't give a [__] about this and then the
reviews came out and it just seemed like no one
was liking this movie and it just sounded awful
and I was like this is going to be like a tedious
boring experience so my expectations and and I
think for most of us were we somewhere towards
the ground they they were very much at the bottom
of the ocean and going into it I maybe that had
something to do with it I'm sure it did I'm I'm
100% confident like if this had crer be like what
the hell is everyone talking about but uh because
they were so bad I watched this and I kind of like
the first Aquaman movie that was where I visually
appreciated it so much so at the time but as a
narrative I thought it was kind of a dull film uh
the characters I thought were boring uh I didn't
I was never emotionally hooked into anything that
really happened I just sort of watched stuff
happen and it was occasionally impressed and
kind of just waited for the next action scene
to happen and this movie moves at such a fast
pace it is a onslaught of noise and and and just
uh Crazy Action but I had so much fun watching
this at times was it paced in a way where cuz you
could always tell like it just seemed like every
single scene was trimmed every single you feel
that not even where trimmed there are definitely
deleted scenes in this experience and a lot tries
to get saved by montages and dialogue overlapping
sequences almost every single scene felt like it
was significantly cut down however I still think
that they managed to find a way to still be I
still feel like the ultimate end product was
probably very self-aware I still think that the
script at hand that just because of certain things
that are happening here that there seem to be
an actual Embrace of the silliness of the cheese
the things that people would say worked about the
prior film I think they just exceptionally tripled
down and then when we were told to cut down the
film they were like well we got to just double
down on that [__] even more we got to just go
through the Mayhem even more because the action
I thought was consistently really entertaining
that first action scene in Atlantis when uh when
when Atlanta the Nicole kimman shows up I had
that thought going of there is just so much
craziness happening here but I can I can easily
keep up with what's going on and and I thought
James Juan's Direction you could actually feel
James ju I feel like you only saw that kind of in
doses in the last Aquaman movie cuz for the most
part I wouldn't feel like James Juan was behind
the camera on that on this one I felt like I was
watching James Juan's camera work for most of the
movie even if it got like you know tarnished via
editing via Studio interference and whatever I
still felt like I saw his camera work on display
where a lot of times it looked really cool so I
found myself laughing at the film I found myself
laughing at the film I found myself laughing with
the film I really enjoyed the action are there
problems so much problems but it constantly made
up for only there was only like a 10 to 20 minute
stretch where I thought it was getting a little
tedious and a little dull but for the most part
I was do something with that would just like pull
me back in like I I had that comment at one point
where I was like this movie should have ended 10
10 to 15 minutes ago and then they go into this
action scene where or and not orm uh Black Manta
and and Aquaman are are Trident trid toting it off
in this crazy one take that looks straight out of
anime movement there a camera movement for it that
I was like wow was worth waiting the extra 10 to
15 minutes for that shot that was freaking cool
you know I had I had a really fun time with this
and I think the effects were dogged on before
watching and are there some pretty bad effects
at times yeah but are there some great effects at
times yeah you know for for every bad thing there
was something that would happen that would just
kind of pull me back in and I would get lost in
this swashbuckling video game anime B movie sci-fi
Mayhem that we were watching so I had fun with the
cacophony honestly I did and um there's no I have
no dog in this fight to defend it the I never do
and and I especially now like it's over the DC
is over what's the point get that last minute
Shilling in so I had I I I actually had uh and
it's probably more fun in in you know in in an
area like this where we can like kind of make fun
of the movie and like audibly sure sure where we
don't all have to be silent and respect yeah and
ourselves through scenes and not like actually
let out our moans and our groans and be like God
this is kind of stupid because I I thought there
was a lot of inventive wackiness and monstrous
Mayhem happening throughout man so um yeah all
right boys flip a coin let's just do this at the
same time yes like the reaction ready go take it
away Andrew take it away all right um well like
you Greg and you John uh I was not the biggest I
I know we're like the three people on the planet
I am the biggest fan of the first yeah we're we're
like the three people on the planet who didn't
care for the first film um yeah no this one I
mean wasn't the greatest film um but I I like Greg
I had a lot of fun watching it um I think you said
it best during the reaction like when I one thing
I do want to quickly touch on I know I said Black
Manta um he's a little more menacing in this I
meant the performance I forgot the actor's name um
not the character itself yes I know he had cordex
was affecting him that whole thing could have
totally been tarnished and I you know you could
have just had the black Trident and that's how
he was able to power up without the whole cordex
thing I think that would have made it a little
bit better so I'm in total agreement there I just
meant his performance was much more menacing yes
we got way more screen time than he did in the
first film I just appreciated his performance
a lot more so I just wanted to clear that up all
right no fighting here Greg um but uh yeah this
film was again my expectations I did not watch any
trailers um for this film because I don't know why
why didn't you invite me um but um special trailer
watch party don't know how to do this on my own
that's true I don't have I don't have access to
the trailer I don't have access to the internet
but no I I I again I wasn't the biggest fan of the
first one so I kind of just avoided the trailers
and uh I did not really have any expectations if
any at all for this film so uh having said that um
I had a lot of fun watching this one and I think
the thing I appreciated the most besides Patrick
Wilson and Jason M Mo's interactions Jason mamo's
energy it just kind of was just so infectious and
just kind of just spread on to the audience if you
will and I just loved his performance so much it
was just fun um also too um who's the elephant
in the room was going to say this but um she was
barely in the film which I I don't think she needs
to be an El the room like she's really skinny I
would call yes yes exactly pretty fit but um I
mean it wasn't really in the film which is fine
I didn't either way didn't really bother me um but
I can't really say anything I would say like from
a narrative point of view like why you making it
weird Andrew why am I making whatever's presence
is like most every other supporting character's
presence doesn't feel particularly pointed I
would say from a Nar I mean if we're going to get
into narratives though in terms of characters and
arcs and all that I mean I I really didn't think
Aquaman had much to do in the film yeah he had
to free his brother and you know there was the
emotional Arc there but terms of a character Arc
like you know accepting being the king and and
that like cuz he kind of said you know in one of
his interactions with his brother that you know I
never wanted to be king I don't like it and then
by the end of the film like okay what has changed
other than uh your brother said like you have to
make the hard decisions and you do that so well
I'm like okay that's it well in the last one he
felt like he wasn't worthy of being King and this
one he learns to kind of be like all right I I'm
okay with being King oh Stell never never mind
I take back everything I that's why they throw
a lot of [__] at your face to distract you okay
but having said that the action sequences were a
lot of fun I'll be at a few CGI things but like
Greg said there were a lot of CGI that I really
did appreciate whereas in the first film again
there were some great CGI shots but there were
a lot to I was just like just jarring for me and
just uh just in your- face not enjoyable in my
sense just taking me out of the film um but this
film I I app appreciate it a lot more um overall
though again it's it was a fun time is the best
word I would use to describe this film um it's
nothing super deep or anything but I don't think
it was trying to be I appreciated how self-aware
it was I mean even called him Loki when I mean I
mentioned you know me my I'm a reference machine
and I even said it's like Thor the Dark World so
like Hey we're trying to do Thor the Dark World
let's just I'm just going to call you Loki here
you know my I mean so I I I actually appreciated
it was aware that how ridiculous it was being
and it was self-aware so I mean he should of
just does the I am Iron Man thing at the end and
I feel like I know they drop yeah totally but uh
yeah no I mean J Mo and and I know this film got a
lower rating score of 5.9 I believe and the first
film got like a 6.8 or whatever I don't care I Who
on IMDb uh I don't care but I like this film more
than the first one personally but I thought it was
more fun at least than the first one you know in
terms of narratives I think they're both shite
but um but I think this one was more if I ever
had to rewatch this one or the second or the first
one excuse me I would definitely rewatch this one
yeah uh I I like if anything at least for the
no I would rewat it for that no no no um yeah I
I just think the seriousness in the first one I
I could never take anything seriously and I was
just either laughing at it or but I feel like I
would laugh at it without it without it like any
any awareness that like this is they really want
to be taken seriously right now and so here they
were like screw all seriousness we're not even
going to really try and really quick to your
point just really quick and I'll let JN go to
your point there was a scene in the very first
film where black manta's uh father was uh about
to die and like he's doing the slow dramatic
run as he I'm like I don't care about either of
these characters and why like No And like with
rer gregson's William uh Williams's music I'm like
this this is so ridiculous how serious it's trying
to be right now and so to your point I completely
agree with you John I felt like melodramatic where
this had no drama it was just brush over the
serious stuff but there's a positive message
and [__] in it it's nice yeah all right John
do all the criticisms sure the lack of Supporting
Cast black Mansa being a weak character yet again
a waste of big villain at the end predictability
come on there's a lot of bad things well this
this is a fun and interesting experience in this
movie because this movie represents uh so many
of the pitfalls that so many other DC EU movies
have had and I feel like yeah on the heels of the
first Aquaman I'm like so much about this movie
is like really similar to that movie uh and even
though that movie has an extra half hours worth of
breathing room this movie having half hours less
Breathing Room comes AC like the first Aquaman is
like the okayest of this entire wave to me it's
like flat in the middle there's not much origal
about it it's a little too serious but it's got
a big imagination in this movie I think there
are a lot of bugs that come out of the choice
to make it fast and Breezy but a lot of those
bugs become features and I think that's what it's
like yeah hearing the response to this movie has
been fascinating because to me especially now
having seen it it feels like a lot of people's
processing of this was very much ingrained in
where it falls in the franchise how much of a
point is there to having this experience at all
if we removed all that I'm sitting here looking
at this and thinking to myself this is a perfectly
fun swashbuckling silly movie that that manages to
go after some of that Lord of the Ring scale but
instead of doing it in all the weight of the crown
and the drama we're going to do it in the scope of
all the crazy ass places we got to go and uh and
yeah I mean you know are is your whole Supporting
Cast like winnowed down to the point where you
forget half them are there until they show back
up again like Amber herd not being here it it
would be one thing if she was the only character
that was happening to but like pretty much every
character I would forget about except for Arthur
and orm and kind of manta Shin is really like the
third guy on that totem pole I was always having
in mind really and then Manta way down here and
then everybody else way down here so yeah like
it's weird there are plenty of criticisms to
Levy and none of that stuff is really what comes
to the Forefront of my mind like it's yeah you
get the glob trotting swashbuckling gallivanting
you get some fun imagination you get your tributes
that are obvious without feeling like they're
too impressed with themselves for doing those
tributes in the first place and uh yeah you know
I I feel like for the conclusion of this it's a
little funky it's a little weird but uh I don't
know I thought the the just the like you said I've
seen a lot of things especially in this wave of
Cinema that are noticeably retooled and reworked
and I've seen versions of that that go over a lot
more poorly than this does so I am kind of f fated
at the response to this being as overtly sort of
like we knew this was going to suck and it did
whereas I sit here and I kind of agree with you
I'm like I would sooner probably throw this on as
opposed to the first movie because at least this
movie you we can get all the angsty [__] out of
the way and now we're just having fun you know and
and like yeah gripes about Manta you know I feel
bad for Yahya because even though I guess he had
more screen time I felt like he had less screen
time and they do that thing that has plagued a lot
of these DC movies black adom comes most freshly
to mind because it was most recent but like yeah
we have this demon guy who looks cool and comes
from a cool place and that guy is basically just
going to take over this other guy who we actually
have like an emotional connection to and then he's
going to become the villain and like it's cool but
also like we just go to Dun Harrow at the end and
do the dead army from Lord of the Rings for a hot
minute and then we're done but like yeah like
that's a TR and like that goes even back to you
you can find that in Wonder Woman and so many
other of the DC movies and that's what I think
is funny here is that they really did just like
pull one of their tricks out and go yeah that's
going to be the villain instead of going with in
relation to this and many other superhero movies
lately I've heard people say we don't always need
the world rending Stakes sometimes personal Stakes
are better and this is an instance where I'm
like damn it man if they just made Black Manta
have all they had to do is have him maintain his
agency he can go team up with cordex or whatever
he wants but like have him maintain the agency so
I care when the character shows up cuz it really
made everything with him super super silly agreed
my big what my biggest comp my biggest complaint
actually over everything is that I think they
bought black man had some cool fight moments
and there were some cool visuals around like I
like the enhancement of the glowing of the red
eyes like through the smoke and the mist and you
just see it like blending in with it I thought
was really cool uh but in terms of a character
you know there is this like big scene where he
you know he's going to he's threatening uh Dr
Shin with the the blade and he's like you want
to know my ultimate plan and he just reiterates
him like yeah there's nothing new here that I
thought we wait he wasn't in on this from like
the very beginning this seems like the exact same
plan and as a character I don't I did I thought
they completely wasted him yet again completely
he's just more more brooding like he was already
one note in the first movie like with this like a
layer of oh I lost my father so I guess it's not
entirely I felt like Yaya was at least bringing
trying to bring like a death to the first movie
and then this one I think he saw how shitty this
was and decided whatever I'm just going to go
full force I'm just aggressive and it was way
more one note uh this movie didn't give a [__]
about that character at all it's very obvious like
Atlanta I don't uh Nicole kimman was like her
presence that's the thing is the it's not just
that they had less screen time it's that their
presence wasn't even felt you would that's why
you would forget about them you know Atlanta she
would be there yeah yeah she's in the movie um and
then merera especially that was the one where I do
think it seems very apparent that they certainly
cut some [__] out it seemed like she should
have been more involved bare minimum requisite
amount they gave her CU because at first she's
in it and I'm you're like why isn't she ever with
him on land with the baby like you never see
them as a family together and there's so much
emphasis on the baby I might care more about this
baby literally Poss the baby's M yeah and then uh
when she shows up when she gets harmed like okay
well she's not going to die maybe should be more
important then she just kind of just shows up for
a couple of few badass moments but she doesn't
feel like a character and I feel like Dolph
London weirdly felt way more like a character
than the other two but that's like a barely a
compliment because he was just that voice The
Voice he kind to do some weird like dude voice the
whole muscle King it's a weird voice yeah but I
liked Patrick Wilson uh I thought he was having
fun it was nice to see them like lining up in a
way that didn't feel like they were sabotaging the
characters that came prior I don't feel like orm
was necessarily a bad guy in the first movie that
I I kind of understood where he was coming from
like yeah if I was in this guy's position I told
it' be like the surfice people are bad why not why
wouldn't you think that and to see them kind of
deconstruct that pull that layer back I thought
was fun him and Jason Mo had good chemistry
great music in this movie throughout and and
again I feel like there's an actual like the first
movie certainly breathes better the first movie
certainly feels like for all for all purposes
it's a movie a movie it actually feels like a
movie and feels like some weird project but Bri
had so much more fun watching this one than I did
the other one they both have these qualities that
feel so requisite in how they're telling their St
stories and I think the choice of pacing this one
this way just works better if you're going to do
that yeah cuz I I at least like um I I still
feel like wow there's some cool James Wan isms
in this one and versus the last one where people
like oh you know that trench scene when they see
the trench people that's like a James one moment
right and Le juanell has a cameo so so it's super
James one but everything else just felt like
it could have been directed by somebody else
and and this was the first time you know there
maybe that had something more to do with more
scenes being not in Ocean uh but a little more
like different locations more land stuff where
but even under underwater I think he he got a
better grip on a lot of the visuals for like
I like the more sci-fi populated cities I really
felt more like oh instead of just populating with
a bunch of CGI creatures I actually got a sense I
bet a lot of it was cut down really get that but
but you got a sense like that gangster World it
feels like Star Wars like everything feels like
it's like you know ripping off something else for
sure they got traffic and they got a bar you know
they got all sorts of stuff they had job of the
Hut they had news yeah just King stuff and Dolph
lren did say that a lot of the film was cut down
so I mean as always you know we got to release
the WAN cut um but I'd say the most unbelievable
thing that we saw especially from black mana's
character especially at the beginning that took
us all immediately out was that the the helmet
we saw was cut straight down but the the scar was
in a diagonal L it's like I don't understand that
yeah it was a weird I mean it probably would look
stupid honestly straight supervision choice just
had the helmet what looks cool on one thing looks
different on another thing so we got to have them
both be cool like it's a movie about a man who can
swim just I mean he barely does King stuff they
have so much so that they have to lay out what he
did at the very end so that way we know what he
did as a king like when orms were citing all that
I was going I didn't really pick up on any of that
all the stuff about you know hey you're willing to
do the hard things and when when doing the wrong
thing is easy and you know even helping out going
to your worst enemy I'm like yeah there's like no
real emotion to any of that [__] throughout this
journey but I'm glad you laid that out doing what
he has to do I'm glad you told me what was going
on yeah but in a way that's better that's that's
good it's we should be able to look back and be
like oh he is right isn't he yeah but for the
tone of this film I mean I don't know I don't
care cuz yeah it was fun it's it's fun there's
somebody there like an actual style to it though
at the same time there's style there's purpose and
there's like truly rewarding action visual scenes
you know it feels like people showed up it feels
like they maintained a spirit of fun along the
way and it feels like they didn't give up when the
movie got gutted like it seems like they really
worked to smooth it out as best they could like
there are sequences in visuals that I would gladly
like look up a clip for you know I don't know if
I'd ever watch this movie start to look up certain
scenes key moments the one where those crabby
things are going it's very inventive there was
that one where the crabby things are going like
into the wall and like that was pretty cool I mean
yeah quite a few of those no it's got a lot of
imagination and a lot of like fun comic book stuff
like this felt more like paging through some kind
of swashbuckling comic book yeah it's more madap
Skull Island it's everything it's a whole bunch of
things it's a whole bunch of movies just smashed
into one yeah in a in a way where once in a while
it's you know at time at times though I did I
would find myself craving all right slow it down
a little bit so because you got to have a bit of a
balance that way the madness can be more rewarding
and enjoyable you you just need that balance to
so because if it's just at one pace which it is
I guess that's if I had one actual gripe it would
be that like I think they could have spent any
amount of time and I know people will winge if
Amber herd's in this movie anymore but I think
it would have been a more conscientious choice to
favor the movie and maybe show them as a family
just a little bit that baby becomes more than
just a literal McGuffin when she's just in like
her same outfit the entire movie just show she
doesn't get more than a couple lines in any of
her scenes which I watched something like this and
I'm like it's distracting I know people lost their
minds when that court case was going on but you
know what make the movie smooth and just feature
her a little bit more in appropriate places yeah
I mean if you're going to feature her you might as
well commit yeah you know like she's going to
she's in it it's not like she shows up in the
beginning and leaves forever like you know she's
you're intermittently placing her throughout you
might as well commit to Arthur's freaking baby and
we barely even spend time like once we leave the
baby after the prologue I had to like the movie
once it cut back I was reminded like oh [__]
he's got a kid that's right oh yeah and I mean
you do see mirror there in the beginning for like
a tiny bit but like her they're leaving yeah I
was like wait a minute where do she's is she like
like sometimes staying here and then she ever come
see the kid Yeah because sometimes she's not like
what is the living situation Arthur with it seems
like Arthur constantly buzzes off and just stays
on land and like screw the kingdom this is where
I sleep this is my home you know but he clocks out
at 6 is like not there ever this is strange I'm
like guys I get it I know you hate this person
for various reasons we won't talk about that it's
a good idea for a spin-off though it would be nice
yeah if if this baby's mother was around if we're
going to commit to the idea that she and Arthur
are still together all right well would you like
more the flash of this Andrew wow what a question
Jesus oh my goodness why do you have to put me on
um oh God H this was definitely more fun I would
probably choose this but oh Michael Keaton's my
favorite Batman the highs and Flash are higher but
this is a much more consistent experience I would
probably choose to watch this but I I but I I'm
like watching Michael Keaton back as Batman but I
I would probably choose this this is a movie I I
wanted to stay looking at no matter what whereas
there are many times during flash where I would
rather not look at what is on screen yeah the
as much as I think the answer should be probably
flash I think I would probably watch this sooner
the two bar Allens just really annoyed me but I
would probably say the uh I'd probably choose this
I feel like the flash is probably a more cohesive
movie much stronger like a more a better movie
probably i' rather watch this I'm talking movie
versus experience sure it's probably a better
conceived and assembled film maybe perhaps also
too being such a fan of flasho paradox in general
I'd rather watch this yeah I just feel like that
was such a misguided decision in general but I
miss Jason I didn't think I would until he was
here he seemed even more even though like a lot
of the takes weren't consistent you could tell
that there were REO he had a tear shedding dud one
scene I mean he committed you got yeah I'm going
to miss him as Aquaman I was like oh you know
what I am going to miss him still hey but the
good news my man yeah he's still going to remain
in the D whatever they're calling it um so that's
good news I guess oh and not I guess I'm happy
he's still sticking around Lobo or what whoever
he's going to be so that's the question because
they don't have any Aquaman stuff slated right
now so are they going to do this thing where
they do like a phase one and then go okay this
is going all right oh we're bringing him back as
Arthur Curry or are they going to go Lobo because
I feel like they could do either one man this is
an ending with huge implications that apparently
is not going to matter at all yeah open nowhere
they gave vibranium to the world it's a huge
ending that's like it's not none of it matters now
yeah go big or go home or go big and go home even
though nothing ended up happening from here are
you guys sad we didn't get a Ben Affleck scene or
a Michael Keaton scene I I just would have loved
to have seen a especially because they actually
got him to come back we saw it and originally
they were supposed to have Michael Keaton do a
scene as well but yeah and I think you are right
like that that whole meeting at the end I'm like
it does seem weird for the Justice League not to
be like here welcome one of our team standing in
the back you know here for support yeah like we
all up we talked about this first remember that
Steen wolf thing yeah I was there to help out I
was a part of that so you guys know me from that
and now I'm in the spotlight here and I want to
talk to you about ecology saving the planet yeah
I mean knowing that this is it I understand why
but yes agreed they they do distracting Justice
League cameos in every other movie they should
have done would it even been cool if they did the
Shazam thing just showing them from the back with
their show them but just their butts all we needed
was Wonder Woman theme them on top of and just
yeah they're all showing up all righty guys what
did you think about Aquaman in the lost kingdom
did you love it did you hate it do you agree with
all the critics do you think it's better than
the first one do you what come on what's your
honest take on it are you going to miss Amber
herd as Queen Mara yes leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that Bell leave a like
and uh we will catch you all flippity Flip Flip
oh